and you'll tell us about some
interesting and new results on learning
tree structure distributions
let's take it away are you yeah so
um i'm going to be talking about
learning tree spectrum distributions
um using an algorithm by chavaloo which
is from 1968
so it's been around a long time people
have been using a lot it has
a wikipedia page with a lot of citations
and the goal here is to give finite
sample guarantees
for how accurately how many samples it
takes
to reconstruct a good tree
so just as uh what is going on
as background that
probably many of people in the audience
understand better than me
um we want to learn some high
dimensional distribution
uh here for this for this talk we're
going to focus on discrete alphabets
so p is over sigma to the n
sigma you can think binary or a small
constant
and we'll give the dependence on sigma
um
and of course learning such a high
dimensional distribution is hard
because there's signal to the end
different degrees of freedom it's going
to take a lot of samples
and so in order to do this you need some
structure structural assumption on p
and one way to impose structural
assumptions is bayes nets
so this is where you have some
underlying dependency graph
and you suppose that p factors very
nicely so the probability distribution
for
every variable only depends on
the parents in the in the graph
and then you can write it down but if
the graph is first you can write it down
very very nicely
another way of expressing high
dimensionalizations is markov random
fields
which is where you look at the cliques
you get some cost for each clique you
take the product
and then you mask the probability for
each
setting of the variable and so again
this is something that you could write
down
it decomposes just as functions of small
pieces of this graph and you can write
it down efficiently
on the icing model of the special case
here
whereas binary and so these make it easy
to write down p
and so you can at least hope to to to
solve the answer unfortunately it's
still
very hard to learn in general what the
distribution is
and so we're going to focus on a very
special case
which is when their graph is a tree
and tree graphs are nice
for a number of reasons one being that
markov random fields and bayes nets are
actually equivalent
for trees the exact same set of
distributions are expressible
under for a given tree and then since
mrfs
don't have a orientation that means in
fact that the the choice of root for
your bayes net doesn't matter either
and so whatever your root is you root
the tree from there
and you can write down a bayes net for
any distribution
that's accessible with any other any
other uh
root on the same tree okay
and so then if your distribution really
is
tree-like then this is great because
you can do computation on these on these
tree structure distributions
very easily for so for whatever
downstream task you have
you can do your computation
and then the hope is that because users
are simple we should be able to learn
them efficiently with the small numbers
um and so in particular what we would
like is we'd like to say
if you can give me any distribution
ideally what we'd be able to say is we
can find
a tree structure negative p hat
that is at most epsilon worse
than the best tree structure
distribution
so here i don't know what tree it is i'm
still going to try and learn
an approximation fee that's almost as
good as the best pre-structured
approximation
and the the way we're going to measure
distance
is with kl's from p to
p hat turns out that this is the
mathematically cleanest way of doing it
if you want something like tv then you
can use pink squares inequality to get
bounds into
so many questions on this setup
all right so
for most of the talk instead of trying
to find a good distribution we're going
to look at structured learning trying to
find
a t such that the best distribution on
that
tree t is close to the vet it's clear
and turns out that finding the tree is
the hard part
once you know the tree estimating the
distribution is is not that hard
and so as now let's talk we're going to
talk about the classic xiaolu algorithm
for learning trees and then realize
that the analysis of it is going to
depend on
independence testing in low dimension
and then we're going to solve
independence testing and no dimension
and then get back to childhood and
and get our good results let our linear
sample result
for for three last words
okay so basic background
um if i have some tree suppose i know
some
t tree t and i want to find what is the
best
approximation to p that is t structure
well the natural solution is to say well
we'll define our
right so p t is a product over the
marginal
because t structured and we'll just
define p t
to match on the marginals with p so we
just look for every
probability of b given a the probability
of e given b the probability of d
given b and take the product of these
and that is
tree structured and we'll just set that
it turns out that that is the
distribution that minimizes the kl
distance
which is really why we're measuring in
that in that in that
distance because it makes this very
clean
not only that um but
tallu showed that
if you measure that distance
to the optimum you can express it as
negative sum over all pairs of the
mutual information
along that pair so in this case it would
be negative mutual friction between a
and b
between b and e between b and d d and f
and c
plus some function
that only depends on the tree and it
doesn't depend
on t some
function involving attribute and so then
the point is this means that the tree
that minimizes
the kl divergence is going to be exactly
the tree
that maximizes
the mutual the sum of mutual
informations over this tree
and these are just pairwise functions
so we just want to find the maximum
weight spanning tree
where we weight every pair by the mutual
information of the two
the variables on both sides of the edge
so this is the chalu observation
and then once you know this then that
gives you a very natural algorithm which
is i just want to find
to find t i take the maximum weight
spanning tree the only problem is i
don't know
what i don't actually know the mutual
information
between x u and x v because i don't know
the distribution on x u and m v exactly
i just have samples
but what is the natural algorithm that
you're going to do well you're just
going to take the empirical mutual
information
you have your empirical you take a bunch
of samples look at the empirical
mutation
compute the empirical maximum expansion
and the hope
is that the results you get will
be optimal or near optimal with a
relatively small number of samples
so this is the setup um this is from
xiaomi in 1968 there's been a lot of
analysis in the past 50 years
um and so for for a while
this analysis much of it focus on asking
when the answer that you get is equal to
the optimal answer
exactly so it gets every edge correct
and so chow and wagner observe the sort
of trivial observation
that as your number of samples goes to
infinity uh
then your error problem is going to go
to zero because you're going to converge
to learning
these mutual informations exactly and
therefore it's going to give you the
correct answer
um and then
a couple more recent papers have
analyzed what the probability of failure
is and show that that failure probably
goes down exponentially
in the number of samples with some
constant cp that depends on their
distribution and it's going to depend on
this administration because
well if i have two edges that are very
very close
then it's going to take a whole lot of
samples to be able to distinguish which
edge you need
right so in this case i really you know
y to z
is slightly better than x to z
but in order to notice this i'm going to
need to take
millions of samples and so
you you can't get a sample complexity
bound that's independent of
the weights of your of your of your p
uh because it's not distinguishable
but of course in this case we don't
actually need to distinguish
ed y z from xz because they're basically
the same
and so this gives a natural question is
what if i don't want to find
the optimum t star i just want to find a
good enough
approximation to test
and so this now is a question of
can i find a t hat such that the kl
divergence
is the most epsilon more than the
optimum chaotic would be
this makes sense so now we can hope to
get a bound that depends on
n and depends on sigma and depends on
epsilon but doesn't depend on p
if so it doesn't depend on the
parameters of my distribution
and so often in 93
actually analyzed basically this there
was a little bit of
difference so he didn't do exactly the
empirical mutual information he he did
um a slight slight variant of empirical
information for for the weights on each
edge but
throwing out some outliers and stuff
like that but but basically does that
and so that you can do this
with o tilde of n squared over epsilon
squared for binary
okay so this is the background and then
what
we show is first we get a bound that's
similar to options for general alphabets
so if you have sigma squared n
plus m squared over epsilon squared then
with high probability
challenge will return a t hat that is
epsilon goes to optimal
and in fact as we'll see this is
basically trivial like if you just plug
in existing results
this is this is clear um there's not
really much
to it um however this is necessary
you can construct distributions such
that finding the bet
finding any epsilon approximate t really
does required n squared over epsilon
squared samples
it's unfortunate because n squared isn't
very good
um and so our next result is to say well
if we're actually a tree right so so the
example where it's hard
is not very close to being a tree it's
not actually tree structure
and so in that case maybe you don't
really need to learn the distribution
as a tree like it's not really you're
not trying to solve a problem that's
very good to solve
and so our main theorem says
if your distribution actually is tree
structured
then we can learn it in n over epsilon
samples
rather than n squared over epsilon
square samples
and when i say we can learn i mean xiao
lu learns it
straight up childhood eric can i ask a
question i'm sort of confused about the
the realizable case i mean if it's a
tree then it's also an icing model and
we should expect
like log and the dimension number of
samples to learn it right
um
oh i see the degree may be unbounded
okay yeah the degree can be unbounded
um but but still
um even more than that like so
i mean you can have just a bunch of
little triangles and i need to know for
each triangle
which one it is that there's some
solvent edge and then the you can have a
gap here where it's
like my mutual information is
um you know epsilon epsilon 0
zero epsilon epsilon so i say epsilon
over n
right if i use two informations on each
edge can be epsilon over n
then whenever i make a mistake i'm gonna
be off i'm gonna lose
epsilon over n and k out
yeah okay okay your your edge your edge
strengths could be so small there i
i understand how the bound com comports
with other work okay
yeah um exactly
so our knob gives an answer which is the
log n is multiplied by exponential and
the coupling strength
and we don't want to assume anything on
the top left string and so if that's
linear then then your bound is going to
be quite bad
so yeah you actually do need n over
epsilon because
in something like this you can have
order n
instances each of which you're off by
epsilon over n
unless you take an n over epsilon
samples to be able to identify what the
situation is
and then similarly people again get the
n squared over epsilon squared by saying
that you can make
n instances each of which have a gap of
epsilon over n that takes n squared over
epsilon squared to learn
okay any other but i guess your point i
guess the point here is that the theorem
doesn't you don't have any conditions on
like the edge strengths
exactly there's no condition on edge
strengths no condition on
condition number for any decision
i guess the reason the reason why you
can get away with that is that you're
not doing
structure learning here per se like
you're not you're not doing you're not
identifying the edges of the graph
you're just coming up with some tree
that
is close that's right so we're not going
to get
exactly the right the right tree um
right and then kostas points out that
there is actually an n log n over
epsilon bound
um so if you yeah i mean so so in this
instance
where you know exactly what the what the
triangles are then it's n over epsilon
but if you don't know exactly what the
what the how the edges are linked up how
the triangles are linked up then you can
get an
and log n over epsilon
in in this lemma that you're calling
trivial like there's also no condition
on the
strength there's no condition
right so i'm saying it's trivial but it
was not previously published
um but it really does follows directly
from previous work
okay good question is it clear from uh
from your analysis what happens when you
have something that's close to being
restructured like how you interpret it
between these two
it i haven't thought about it that
carefully
um
yeah there's there's a couple places
where you need to be careful about how
you define being close to tree structure
i think
um but it seems plausible to me that you
can make it yeah it seems
likely to me that you can make it work
as long as i'm epsilon close to being
tree structured
but i'm not actually sure how it works
all right cool thanks yeah
okay so then of course this is about
giving you a bound in kl
if i want something in tv you can use
princess inequality and so
that gives you square root so then
you're going to get a 1 over epsilon
squared instead of 1 over epsilon
but it'll still be linear in it
and then costas and vascolacus and penn
concurrently have very similar results
so
for they also get a linear a near linear
bound
um in the binary case
so they're in the binary case for tv but
they're actually optimal so
we get n log squared and they get
n log which is in fact necessary
for the for the even for the binary
realizable case
okay so let's try and prove that
the trivial level um so again we have
that
by chow and liu the cost we have
is some constant that's independent of
the tree minus
the weight of the tree and the mutual
information
and so for any t whatever we pick
our kl divergence is going to be opt
plus however much worse our weight is
and so the only question is can we find
an approximately
lar sufficiently good maximum weight
spanning tree
approximate the maximum weight weight
getting that whose weight is at least
epsilon
left at no more than epsilon less than
than the optimum and the obvious
algorithm is just to do the empirical
m maximum weight spanning tree where you
weight by the empirical
mutual information
and so again right so we get this t hat
that maximizes the empirical weight
and we want to say that this is epsilon
clause
so that means we want the impera the
weights
to be epsilon close so it suffices to
ensure that
for every tree our estimate of its
weight is epsilon over two plus
because then the optimum or i'm going to
we're only going to view as being
epsilon over two worse whatever we
output is only epsilon or two better
and so if it seems like it's better than
the optimum then it has to be within
epsilon
so as long as every tree is is estimated
to within epsilon number two we're going
to be good
okay well each tree is a sum
of this is first the sum of
mutual relations between x hat and x
u and x hat and v and so in order for
for
for this gap to be epsilon over two
it suffices to have each individual term
be within epsilon over 2 divided by the
number of terms
and it's a tree there's only n minus 1
terms
so it suffices to have the individual
mutual informations
be epsilon over n plus for all pairs
so then that answers the question okay
how many samples do we need
for the empirical mutual information to
be close to the actual mutual equation
with high probability then we can take a
union down and be there
okay so this is a question about mutual
information estimation we have some
samples from sigma across sigma
low dimensional and we just need to know
we want to estimate the mutual range
with an epsilon
well mutual information is a difference
of of entropies sufficient aspect each
entropy to within
epsilon number two people have done this
people have spent a fair amount of time
analyzing the plug-in estimator for
mutual for
as mutual iteration and the result of
antos
and janus shows that you can do this
with sigma squared over epsilon plus one
over epsilon squared times some log
factors
now for child lu we wanted to estimate
to error epsilon over n
so we plug in epsilon over n and we need
a high probability so delta is one over
n
and so you get that n times sigma
squared over epsilon plus
n squared over epsilon squared times log
factors
so with this many samples every single
mutual information
will be epsilon n over n close therefore
every tree
will be epsilon over two close therefore
whatever tree you output is epsilon
close to the best
which means by kl divergence is epsilon
close to the best
that are the best
so this proves a lot
unfortunately that n squared we have
is in fact necessary you can't
beat the n squared for this one
why is that well it's
so the hard instance
so we're going to take a four variable
case where we have a central
say in the binary setting we have some
iid w that's zero or one and then y is
equal to w with probably three fourths
z with three fourths x with three
fourths all right so this is some tree
and so then the correlation between the
the leaves of this tree is going to be 5
8 because it's 3 4 squared plus 1 4
squared is 10 16
is 5. okay
now what happens if we vary these
weights by epsilon
so if we make these be three-fourths
plus epsilon three-fourths minus epsilon
then what happens is that the x to z and
x to y
wait change by epsilon squared or the y
to z weight changes by
epsilon so the y to z is significantly
less than x to the y and x now this
doesn't really matter
for finding the right tree on w x y z
because the right tree is
w is is the the the w to x w to y w to z
and these are a constant amount better
than the others and so it only takes a
constant number of samples to find those
but what happens but but actually
figuring out
whether you know that x is the one with
plus epsilon
rather than y rather than z well you
need to just identify a biased coin in
my one-fourth
free-force plus epsilon over
three-fourths minus epsilon that's going
to take one over epsilon-squared
you don't need to to find the tree
because you just you know what the tree
is
but consider
if i don't have w i only have
x y and z from this distribution
and i still want to find the best tree
on
x y and z
so i've generated x y and z from this
tree on four variables but i only give
you the three values
then the best tree in this case is going
to be x to y and x to z
not y to z because y and z are less
correlated
by epsilon by the way that i've
constructed
but because even if i told you w
identifying that x was the more likely
one would take one or four squared
then if i tell you this x y and z it's
going to take you 1 over epsilon squared
to identify this best tree
on the other hand the mutual information
between y and z
really is order epsilon worse than the
mutual translation between x and y
and x and z so i really do need to learn
that x is the relevant one to find it
and therefore in the n equals three case
finding the best tree really does
take 1 over epsilon squared samples not
1 over x
and that's n equals 3. if i have general
n what do i do well i just make a bunch
of independent copies of this
and each one of them i make their make
the gap be epsilon over n
and so then it takes n squared over
epsilon squared to get each one with
constant probability
so if i have fewer than m squared over
epsilon squared samples
then i'm going to get 10 of these these
estimates wrong
my error my my the weight of my spanning
tree is going to be
off by 10 of n times epsilon over n will
be
order epsilon
and so in this instance it really does
take n squared over epsilon squared just
to
to find the largest tree
so that's unfortunate because we don't
want to do n squared we'd like to do
that
um but again this is an example
where it's not actually tree structured
on x y and z
it's starting that w x y and z we don't
have w and so
finding the best tree here isn't
actually a very good thing because it's
not
it's not actually very close to tree
structure and if you try to
construct such an example with
a actual
tree you find that it's hard
that
that you you can't make it
yeah you'll find that that you run into
difficulties and and this is why
so if x y and z are actually three
structured
so say if it really is generated x to y
y to z
then we're going to show that you can do
it in order o tilde of one over epsilon
like one reps on log one or epsilon
samples other than one or epsilon
squared
and the point is we don't need to
estimate every mutual information
up to order epsilon that's hard
estimate learning the mutual information
is hard but we don't need that
all we need to know is the relative
mutual
relative order of the mutual formations
we need to know
if the mutual infringement y and z is
bigger than between x and z
then we should find s
which means equivalently we need to be
able to estimate the difference
of mutual informations
and so what happens is if the mutation
between y and z
is very close to that between x and z
then x and y have to be very very
correlated
and so your estimate of the of the
mutual between y and z and between x and
z are very very correlated
and so your errors are going to cancel
when you subtract
that's a bit of intuition the key
observation
mathematically is that if i take this
difference mutual freedom in y and z
minus between x and t
this is equal to the mutual relation
between y and z conditional and x
minus the mutual integration between x
and z conditioned on y
how do you prove this well you just
rearrange terms so if i take
the mutation between y and z plus y and
z conditional on x
this is equal to mutual revision between
y x and z
because there's this conditional the
chain rule of mutual information
similarly if i take if index uh
sorry and
this one if i take
the mutual relation between x and z
plus the mutual between y and z
condition on x again i get neutral
integration between y
and x conditionals and so this again e
is just
a rearrangement of the chain rule of
mutual information
and then the observation is well in
order for it to be bad
in order to actually care if i mistake y
z for x z
this left difference has to be at least
epsilon
on the other hand because i'm actually a
tree and this is where we use that it's
realizable
the usual information between x and z
condition on y
needs to be zero because that's
what graphic models give you x and z are
independent condition on y
and so that means then that the mutual
range between y and z conditional x
better be at least epsilon
and so now if i want to know if is this
difference greater than or equal to zero
it's now a question of testing rather
than learning
because the same equality happens
for the empirical mutual informations
and so the mutual information between x
and z given y
is zero and so the imperial community of
information if i just want to test
our x and z independent condition on y
will be less than epsilon over 10 with
the small numbers now
and y and z condition on x are not
independent
and so i just need to test that and i'll
get that my empirical mutual information
is more than a constant times epsilon
so then when i subtract i'll get
something bigger than zero and therefore
the empirical
estimate will choose y z over x z and it
won't make a mistake
so we're saying that as long as we can
test we can distinguish
when the conditional information is zero
from when it's big
look at the next one then
we're not going to make any mistakes
that are important
and so we're going to be able to learn
the three n equals three case in o tilde
one over epsilon samples
as long as we can test you know tilde
one or epsilon samples
so estimating the mutual information
itself is hard
but just testing if the mutual
information is zero or big
is not so hard saves this quadratic
factor
so that's why we're now talking about
independence
so here the basic question is how many
samples do i need
to distinguish my muturation being
equal to zero as it is on the right from
being
bigger than epsilon
it's a little complicated so let's start
with a similar version of
just independence testing not
conditional independence testing if i
just get
pairs over to finite alphabet i want to
distinguish
are is my are x and y independent or not
are they far from independent in mutual
information
and then for the actual challenge
algorithm we need that the test
statistic that we use
is the empirical statistic i think it's
an interesting question whether you
could avoid that and take
and apply a general statistic
but because we use this identity
for the test statistic as well
it's actually very helpful for us that
our test statistic is the mutual
empirical information so that is that it
satisfies the scientific as well
so mutual information testing
is something that people have studied in
property testing for for a while
but mostly they've been focused on
testing
with distance measured in total
variation so distinguishing
uniform or mute distinguishing
independent from far from independent in
by epsilon and total variation um
and so there have been works by jack
nicholas and kane as well as something
i did that try and really nail down the
dependence on the alphabet size
and on epsilon and on variable
for this problem and then canon de
nicolas kane and stuart
extended this to conditional
independence testing and also got
exactly the right dependence as a
function of
the alphabet size um
when you're measuring it distance in
terms of variation
and then they apply this for measuring
distance in mutual information as we
actually care about
but they get a one over epsilon squared
bound
because they're just applying their
total variation tester to kl and so they
observed that
this is that their their heart instances
don't seem to require
and so it seemed likely to them that you
could do better
which in fact we're going to do and so
our goal is now to get a one or epsilon
bound
with some dependence on sigma which may
not be often but
we'll be polynomial
and so this is our theorem it says as
long as n over log n
is bigger than sigma squared over
epsilon
then with high probability
the empirical information is within a
constant factor
plus or minus epsilon of the actual
interference
so this is an approximation but it's
sort of pretty weak it's saying
we can lose a constant factor and we
could lose epsilon or we could gain a
cost factor and gain epsilon
but the consequence of this is that we
can distinguish
mutual inflation being zero from being
bigger than epsilon
because if we're zero our estimate will
be less than epsilon over 10
if we're bigger than epsilon our
estimate will also be will be bigger
than epsilon number
and so that's all we need for
and then we're going to extend this to
conditional mutual information which is
actually what we need
but it's losing another factor of signal
now these dependencies on sigma are
probably wrong
even from mutual information even for
the empirical statistic
let alone arbitrary statistics but these
are the right
epsilon dependence you can't do any
better than that which
for application where we really care
about epsilon because epsilon over n
is what matters
okay so
let's describe
some simple examples so in the symmetric
case
suppose i have that x is equal
to y with probability p so my mutual
information being 0
would be saying that p is a half
so if i want to estimate p
right so if my information is more than
epsilon because
mutual information because entropy is a
quadratic
i only need to estimate p up to error
square root epsilon
so distinct so if x equals y probably
a half plus squared epsilon it's still
the case the mutual information is only
epsilon
and so sure estimating it up to that you
lose a quadratic factor but you gain a
quadratic factor from
the from from the entropy being
being
having derivative of zero here
and so in this case yeah it only takes
one reps on squared one over epsilon
samples
to estimate p up to squared epsilon
which gives you epsilon
in mutual formation another
trivial case is suppose that x is always
equal to y
but its probability of being non-zero is
p
well now my mutual information is just
the entropy of p
and so my information is zero if and
only if p is zero or one
and if it's bigger than epsilon then p
has to be
bounded away from zero one by at least
epsilon over log
so now this is the question of
distinguishing a coin with probability
zero from a coin with probability
epsilon over log whereas
well you flip it one over that many
times
and you're probably gonna see a heads if
it is
non-zero and so you're gonna be able to
do this
and then the general case let's let p y
be the probability that x is 1
conditioned on a given value of y
and so my mutual information is the
entropy
of h of x which is the entropy
entropy of the expectation of p y minus
the expectation of the entropy and so
what's going on here
is i have py being taking one of
two values and my mutual information
is this gap between
the entropy at the expectation and the
expectation of the answer
and the point is well the linear terms
here cancel
and your error if you tailor expand
around this average
your error only depend your error
depends quadratically
on p1 minus p0
and so okay there's some log factor from
h double prime well this means you only
estimate p up to square root epsilon
which again only takes one over epsilon
samples
so this is for the binary case in
general what we do
is we say do you you you take
their mutual information which is
a kl divergence and
you can express it in terms of delta x y
which is how far how different it is
from being independent
and you can subtract off the linear term
because the linear terms all sum to zero
because the sum of p x y is one the sum
of p x v y
and when you do this you get
that your mutual formation is a sum of
terms
each of which is positive and
when a zero when they're near zero is
quadratic
not linear and so then it suffices
to estimate every one of these
individual terms
well up to constant factors plus or
minus
and so if i want to estimate each of
these individual terms well okay
you do some turn off analysis and you
can get this done
which i'm going to skip because just
basic turn off bound a little bit of
analysis
and so that gives you independence
testing um
which is in the unconditional case if i
want conditional independence testing
well there must exist some value of z
that are far from independent and so i
just need some
i need a number of samples from that z
and so you lose a factor of sigma to get
enough samples for the particular z that
makes it
non-independent and so then you can get
the conditional
all right so back to how we apply this
so for the n equals three case remember
we're trying to say if it's important to
pick y z over x z
then the difference must be bigger than
epsilon
which means that well
x to z given y is zero the other must be
at least epsilon
and so our empirical tester because it
gets a constant factor plus or minus
epsilon
is going to have the second term b's
less than epsilon over 10 the first term
be bigger than epsilon over 2.
and so the difference is bigger than 0
and so we're not going to make a mistake
great what happens in general
well suppose we make a mistake and pick
some edge wz that's not in the true tree
we can walk in the true tree from w to z
and because we have a spanning tree
there must be there's some edges between
w
and z that are in the true tree that we
didn't pick
turns out simple induction says you can
pair them up
you can pair your edge to an edge that
you didn't pick that you should have
picked
in a way so that each edge you you
didn't pick gets paired to a unique one
that you did
on this path
and the claim is that difference
if i made the mistake that difference
can't be very big
and so it can't matter much
suppose it's not true well then
the mutual arrangement x from y minus mu
from wz has to be by definition
at least epsilon over n and now we want
to do the same trick we did for n equals
three
so we do this by introducing the
information between z and y
subtract it and add it and now the left
term
and the right term are both differences
with only three variables
and so we can apply the same n equals
three case
and we get that a difference of
conditional mutual informations and a
difference of conditional information
mutual information and you look at the
negative terms
both of these are zero because x and z
condition on y is zero w and z condition
on y
is also zero
and then because mine bigger than
epsilon over n
one of the positive terms must be at
least half that
and so when i look at the empirical
values
well with n over epsilon samples so
tilde then are some samples my empirical
values for the ones that are independent
will be less than epsilon over 10 n
and for whichever one is large
will be more than epsilon over 4.
and so then and the other one i don't
know but it's non-negative because it's
mutual formation and so when i add that
i'll get something positive
and that says i would not have made this
mistake
so i will never make a mistake by more
than epsilon over n
and so that means that the total number
the sum over all mistakes i make is less
than epsilon
which means i find the good tree
natural question is okay if this is for
structure learning what if i want to
actually learn the distribution
so that means i need to estimate p t the
natural suggestion
is to do the empirical estimate this
doesn't quite work
because kl divergence is very sensitive
to having zeros
so if my empirical estimate is zero
somewhere because i just never see a
rare value
then i'll get infin an infinite kl
divergence
the standard answer for this is well i
shouldn't be totally surprised by
something i didn't see
let me use laplace's rule of succession
so i just
add do an add one estimate suppose in
every alternative i get one more of them
and then you can say that this works
and to prove this we just need to say
that they had one estimate
converges is very accurate in kl
this was proven in previous work in
expectation
but we actually needed a high
probability so we can union bound over
all all the
all the vertices but it's actually quite
straightforward in fact it used the same
decomposition that we had
where we subtracted off the linear terms
and get something in terms of a
quadratic and uh
x log x so it's actually really the same
technology
to to get conversion that that one
estimator is accurate with high
probability in kl
and that's they see it so we get n
squared or epsilon squared sample
suffice in general um
but when you're actually structured then
you can do a nano reaction
it's a number of obvious questions so
one would be to get optimal log factors
so as i said this glucose and pan can
get this for binary alphabets
what if we have a general alphabet um
another is the dependence on our
alphabet size is presumably wrong
and this is true even for conditional
independence testing so if you could
improve the conditional
ancestor that would immediately give you
a better um
a better bound for childhood and then
okay you can look at continuous
distributions like gas and graphical
models
and you can look at bounded tree width
would be a natural extension of trees
so thank you
cool thanks eric it's really interesting
do people have questions
yeah i have a question so among these
obvious questions that you mentioned
like um is there
would it just be like an ob wow would it
be to some sort of extension
like repeating this game or um
other new ideas for example needed to
deal with continuous distributions right
so
what are some like obvious roadblocks
from like generalizing this result
yes well so continuously students i
don't actually know very well
um i think you know costa sent me an
email
yesterday saying that he thinks they
know how to do continuous distributions
um but i i haven't thought about that at
all
um for ben better dependence on
sigma the obvious the the roadblock is
um our exact
theorem statement is not true with a
smaller signal
so we say that like we say that the
mutual ratio between x hat
and y hat is theta of mutual information
between x and y minus epsilon plus or
minus epsilon
and that's not true with less than sigma
squared samples
and sigma q what do you do with the
conditional version
but we don't actually need that so what
will happen when you have fewer samples
than that
is that the mutual information is going
to
seem bigger than it actually is because
there will be some spurious correlations
because you don't have very many samples
but if you're not independent it'll
probably
seem even bigger than it actually is
than if you are independent
and so the same thing happens in
uniformity testing which is really a
special case of
of independence testing when it's
uniform um
so i want to test if something is
uniform then the empirical
tester works well below the regime where
it's accurate
in estimation
because it's still
you know there's still a bias to be
smaller if i am independent
if i am uniform than if i'm not so here
you should expect a bias to be smaller
if i am independent
bounded tree with i also haven't thought
that
very carefully um
you know you're gonna get something
exponential in the truth
so your algorithm is not as clean um but
but
it seems likely that should just be
doable
okay thank you
eric i have a quick question so um i
guess you've thought about using
some of these more sophisticated entropy
estimators to estimate your mutual
information instead of the plug-in
um so the problem is
estimating mutual information really
does take one or epsilon squared
because if you think about like you know
you could gain a long factor somewhere
what is it you could potentially gain in
a log factor somewhere
oh yeah
i'm wondering if that's the if that's
the extra log factor that you have
right so i mean
yeah so we're using union bounds all
over the place
and so when you add a lot as a log
factor then it becomes very
very nice then you can just use use
union bands
and not worry about about averaging
things
um so think like
if you go through kl to bound tv you
have to lose
a log at least in one over epsilon
because like
you gave an example lyric where i think
i think you gave it like
where the neutral information
is epsilon over log one over epsilon but
the tv is absol
like or the other way around right so
you can tv is that one of the larger
apps on the new transformation is
absolutely yeah
yeah so if you go through like kl
uh you have to lose this factor
right yeah um
right and so then like your epsilon if i
when i do these independent copies i get
and i have n versions of this so we have
to have someone so you sort of lose a
log n over epsilon it's not
i'm not sure that you need to lose
you lose a log one over epsilon i have
to think about whether you lose also the
log n
right because you know your effective n
is epsilon over n
when you when you do these n copies
which is
but then it's not good you but then
there's also a login that you lose
from learning to start learning the
structure so it's not clear if
you need both at the same time but
it seems plausible you would
cool thanks eric is there is there sorry
eric is there like a quote-unquote
trivial lemma for
like the bounded tree with case or does
that become non-trivial
so
yeah yes i i it's not
totally clear what the algorithm is um
for bounded tree with case
because you're not i guess you've got to
be looking for a
maximum bounded tree width
graph for mutual information so yeah
it's not it's not
it seems likely that people have studied
this but i i don't know what
what algorithms or even the algorithms
people have done
okay
perfect well thanks eric um the next
speaker
is antonio blanco and he'll talk in
eight minutes so there's a little bit of
a break
look we go get some more coffee and
he'll tell us about
uh hardness of identity testing for some
families of graphical models
so see everybody in